Dana White head of UFC comes
out and he destroys a reporter he didn't
he didn't hold a press briefing he held
a press beating for some reporter who
questioned what sort of things UFC
fighters can and cannot say you
obviously give a Long Leash to your
Fighters about you know what they can
say when they are up there with a UFC
microphone and you are getting into
territory of homophobia transphobia like
is there I don't give anybody a leash
well I'm saying you a leash I'm like
free
speech control what people say going to
tell people what to believe going to
tell people I don't tell any other human
being what to say what to think and
there's no leashes on any of
them what is your
question I was asking that question I'll
move on though yeah probably a good idea
you that's ridiculous to say I give
somebody a leash
Free Speech Brother people can say
whatever they want and they can believe
whatever they
want good
answer
though it's a good answer like he
destroyed this reporter
though in the reporter's
defense do we really think Dana White
would be totally fine with his Fighters
saying anything or saying anything from
a UFC
platform you know if his Fighters came
out and said
we need
to we need to go and behind their
parents' backs and you know he came out
and he was wearing a big rainbow leotard
while he said do you think Dana White
would be totally fine with that what if
take the weird sex stuff out of it what
if a UFC fighter came out and said we
need to support Isis we need death to
America we need to uh support all of the
terrorist regimes around the world and
we would be much much better off forget
about that even what do you think Dana
White would support it if some UFC
fighter came out he said black people
they're the worst people in the world we
should kill them all yeah yeah
absolutely that's what I said at my
UFC press conference no I don't think so
I think Dana White would probably have a
problem with all of those things rightly
so but Dana White doesn't need to worry
about his Fighters doing that because
Dana White has cultivated a stable and
unified culture at UFC everyone is
broadly on the same page they might
disagree on this issue or that issue on
this thing or that thing but they all
share basic premises they got the same
basic attitude they all work together
and fight together they all seem to get
along together pretty well that's why it
works that is why Dana White is able to
afford his employees so much freedom of
speech because it's true Freedom these
are very disciplined guys if you're
fighting in the UFC you are a very
disciplined person okay you work very
hard you know how to control yourself
you understand how to respect limits
that are imposed by you on
yourself that is how American free
speech works worked for most of our
history the reason it broke down is
because of the breakdown of the limits
ironically it's not that we just started
imposing limits all of a sudden it's
because of the breakdown of those
self-imposed limits or there will be
order okay there there will be some kind
of cohesion it'll either be U something
cultivated and habituated from within or
it will be imposed from without with a
very heavy hand but there will be order
Nikki Haley theoretically the last
Republican under and Donald Trump in the
primary in the leadup to New Hampshire
on NBC News has played the race card we
were the only Indian family in our small
southern town I was teased every day for
being
Brown so anyone that wants to question
it can go back and look at what I've
said on how hard it was to grow up in
the Deep South as a brown girl anybody
can look at my record and see when
Walter Scott was shot down by a dirty
cop how I made sure that the Walter
Scott family didn't suffer because we
put the first body camera bill in the
country in place anybody can look at the
fact that when we had nine amazing Souls
dying mother Emanuel Church I did
something that no Republican or Democrat
ever wanted to touch which was call for
the Confederate flag to come down
because it would take two-thirds of the
house in Senate and was an impossible
feat I don't know what you're implying
with that but what I will tell you is
saying that I had black friends is a
source of Pride saying that I had white
friends is a source of Pride you know I
really like Nikki Haley personally
and I like a lot of the candidates in
this race and and all of the candidates
at some point will say something that's
a little hyperbolic or that I don't
quite believe and I got to tell
you I'm a little skeptical that
Ambassador Haley was bullied every
single day of her life as a child for
being Brown and the reason I'm a little
skeptical
is had she not told me I would not know
that Nikki was brown she's very
light-skinned her her parents are Indian
they're Punjabi so that's nor Northern
India where there are a lot of people
who are very light-skinned and I'm not
even saying that no one ever made a
comment about it when she was a kid
probably someone did at some point maybe
someone figured it out and
but every day she was bullied for being
Brown I'm a little skeptical why is
Ambassador Haley saying this I suspect
she's saying this because she's doing an
interview on NBC and they're accusing
her of being a racist like they do to
every single Republican and this is her
natural reaction and this is the natural
reaction of many many Republicans Nikki
Haley is far from alone in this kind of
a response but I think this kind of
response is ill advised because what
this response amount amounts to is
accepting the leftist
framing Nikki Haley are you racist I'm
not racist I'm
oppressed I hear this all the time one
time I was in Washington DC and the
Black Hebrew Israelites were on the
street they're the ones who scream out
and they say white people are the devil
and they're disgusting and they're the
demons and they're you know the ice
people and whatever they all these crazy
racial theories and they yell me and
things at women and all this stuff and
so I was standing in line at a coffee
shop afterward there was a gal in front
of me this little white gal wearing a
North Face jacket and and she goes oh
did you hear those people out there oh
yeah yeah did you could you believe they
they called a white devil and an awful
woman and every and I told him this is
crazy I'm a woman I'm oppressed
too and I I
couldn't I just turned away from her
when I heard that I thought lady you
took you've taken exactly the wrong
lesson from this you're trying to play a
game that you will certainly
lose first of all young affluent white
girl in a North Face in Washington DC
you're not oppressed okay at all at all
by historical standards you are the
least oppressed human being that has
ever existed
ever we're all oppressed by sin and the
fallenness of this world but you in you
in particular
uh-uh but a lot of a lot of people think
well look that's just that's just the
culture right now is just this it's this
race hustling oppression Olympics and
I've got to play it or I'll be totally
cast out so no no I'm actually oppressed
somehow I there are men today I'm not I
I actually remember the story when I was
in college there are straight guys who
will call themselves non-heterosexual
they'll call themselves queer they could
they could be dating women they could be
not they've never done anything weird
never even tap danced okay and they'll
say I'm a non-heterosexual or I'm queer
because they just need a struggle you
know if you're a rich successful white
guy you need some kind of a struggle in
in this oppression Olympics I just think
it's it's going to make you lose from
the beginning if Nikki Haley wins by
accepting the framing that the the south
is evil and white people oppress the
brown people and it's you know this is a
systemically racist country I'm not
saying she's going to go that far but
that's what she's leaning into toward in
this kind of an answer if she does that
then even if she wins she lost you know
if we as Republicans do this then any
Victory will be a pic Victory because we
will only have won by embracing all of
the left's premises this is what happens
when the libs or when the conserv is
rather they tout how you know we we have
conservative activists you know you
don't listen I if you're a activist you
don't need to be with those liberals you
can vote with us well not not really
right you know like we if you think a
man can become a woman then you're
you're not really conservative at
all no no but they support low taxes too
okay well you know life's about more
than low taxes guys if we just embrace
all of the left's fundamental points
then we Just Surrender and even if we're
in office we're just kind of like
zombies just doing the bidding of the
left totally infiltrated by the left
possessing our minds don't do that not
not good stuff that was a good clip huh
that was a good clip and you know it and
I know it and we both know it well if
you want more you got to ring the bell
and then you'll get the notifications
and you'll see more of this face and
hear my malifu tones and we'll get to
spend some time together all right see
you next time